revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 y me acompaña nuestro estudio
Marta Moya Marta bienvenida buena mañana
de viernes Ya finalizamos esta semana
que promete además finalizar bien movida
noticiosamente sobre todo con el
conflicto en Ucrania que es el que vamos
a hablar con usted en este momento
porque vamos a hacer un repaso de la
prensa internacional con esta escalada
de tensiones protagonizada Por quién por
el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin con
Afirma de la anexión de estos
territorios ucranianos tras estos
referentes tildados ilegales por buena
parte de la comunidad internacional
organizaciones internacionales y por
supuesto Porque empezamos con el there
speaker Buenos días Raúl Así es Parece
que la semana va a acabar por todo lo
alto y empezamos con esta revista
alemana the speaker que titula
peligrosamente débil lo que Putin
arriesga ahora para salvarse en esta
portada vemos a Putin ensangrentado con
el ojo morado y que refleja este ojo el
mapa de Ucrania vamos ahora a ver qué
dice el New York el New yorker pregunta
Qué pasa si ya estamos peleando en la
tercera guerra mundial con Rusia hace
una Bueno un análisis sobre que está
pasando en estos últimos días tras la
escalada de tensión por parte del
kremlin y dice que las últimas
provocaciones de Putin ponen una vez más
en aprieto o sea Washington
provocaciones como el chantaje nuclear
La anexión ilegal de los territorios
ucranianos la movilización parcial o la
explosión de los gasoductos del nostrim
que el New York y el New yorker ya
atribuye directamente a Moscú dice que
durante estos meses vaiden se ha
centrado en ayudar a Ucrania y en ganar
tiempo para evitar una hipotética
tercera mundial Pero qué estrategia que
esta estrategia no estaría funcionando
porque las amenazas de Putin mantienen a
todo el mundo como rehén de sus deseos
después dice que la con la
contraofensiva ucraniana en harkif
supuso que Putin escalara Esta esta este
conflicto y que una negociación con
occidente sostiene el New yorker dice
parece Claro que negociar ahora sería
una concesión extraordinaria en sí misma
a la barbarie y a la voluntad de Putin
de amenazar con un conflicto nuclear
increíble Marta
mosquitimes el Times titula Putin
siempre elige la escalada dice que esta
retórica belicista supone que la guerra
ya no está a 1000 kilómetros de Moscú
porque habrá familiares amigos y colegas
están llamados y enviados al frente
después de todo dice no hay signos de
disidencia pese Al poco apoyo de las
élites al presidente Putin que incluso
los oligarcas que están en contra de la
guerra están ayudando a sí mismo a que
la economía se mantenga a flote este
artículo del mosquite Times habla con
Fuentes anónimas cercanas al kremlin y
dice que Putin no puede perder esta
guerra además dicen que las órdenes del
kremlin son una guerra larga y que ya
está casada para hasta 2025 claro Marta
y es que ya yo creo que se convirtió
también en una capricho una decisión
personal del presidente Vladimir Putin
por encima de todo por encima de todas
las recomendaciones incluso de la
humanidad cambiamos
y la mayoría de de de las personas en
noticia de nuestra región Marta las
puertas de las elecciones generales de
Brasil ayer tuvo lugar como ya lo vimos
el último debate televisivo presidencial
marcado por la atención como recoger
esto las portadas de la prensa brasileña
empezamos con el folio de Sao Paulo Así
es entramos ya en los últimos dos días
previos a posiblemente las elecciones
más importantes de la región y la
de Sao Paulo titula En referencia al
debate de ayer Lula mantiene el 50% de
los votos válidos bolsonaro se queda con
el 36 muestra esta imagen de los siete
candidatos presidenciales Y bueno pues
este titular apunta a que Lula todavía
está bueno A las puertas de incluso
poder ganar en primera vuelta bueno que
es el correo 2020 el correo titula los
insultos perjudican el debate final
entre los presidenciables sostiene este
esta portada que fue un debate confuso
lleno de cruces de acusaciones y donde
ningún candidato ganó ni siquiera el
electorado por esta polarización y esta
tensión el estado de minas el estado de
minas titula muchas acusaciones ofensas
Y algún debate En referencia Pues a lo
Bronco que fue este último debate
electoral a apenas 48 horas de que las
urnas abran en Brasil y las elecciones
también atraen a los analistas no no y
los análisis y toda la cobertura de la
prensa internacional desde Francia hasta
el continente asiático vamos a empezar
Precisamente en Francia con lemont Lemon
también hace referencia a este último
debate televisado y titula entre
bolsonaro y Lula un último debate
venenoso en Brasil sostiene este
artículo de Lemon que ambos candidatos
los que tienen más opciones a la
presidencia intercambiaron mensajes de
odio en este de tres horas y que bueno
Esto es en el marco de las elecciones
más polarizadas de Brasil en la historia
reciente algeciras
titula crecen las alertas
internacionales por la amenaza a la
democracia en Brasil dicen que bueno
está estos mensajes de bolsonaro e
intentando poner Elevar El fantasma del
fraude electoral al respecto de las
elecciones y del sistema de votación
electrónica genera preocupación en la
comunidad internacional porque
eventualmente bolsonaro no no reconozca
estos resultados dice que el senado de
Estados Unidos aprobó el miércoles una
resolución apoyando unas elecciones
libres y es sin violencia política que
es un poco lo que ha venido rigiendo
estas últimas semanas en Brasil además
pide que el gobierno de vaiden reconozca
rápidamente al vencedor de la noche del
2 de octubre para evitar posibles
desórdenes el nuevo general el New
Herald abre y dice
Qué pasará si Lula gana las elecciones
hace un análisis más en prospectiva y
sostiene bueno que si el candidato del
partido de los trabajadores gana las
elecciones las siete principales
economías de América Latina estarán
regidas por gobiernos de izquierda pero
que sin embargo pues este Fender
izquierdista no sería poderoso por los
problemas internos en el seno de estos
países y además la crisis financiera e
inflacionaria finalizamos más de esta
revista de prensa con una caricatura Así
es hablamos del Brasilia una caricatura
de chica y Lucas verti que dice primera
o segunda vuelta Esa es la cuestión y
como Ven aquí en pantalla está el
candidato Lula da Silva corriendo por
acercarse a ese 50% y bolsonaro
impidiéndoselo a toda Costa veremos qué
pasa vamos a ver qué pasa Marta Gracias
por esta introducción que precisamente
vamos a seguir ampliando desarrollando y
analizando con nuestro primer invitado
el día hasta el lunes buen fin de semana
Igualmente Raúl gracias gracias a ti
Marta pasamos